مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في العالم العربي
بشكل عام وفي الاردن وتونس بشكل خاص ضجت
بتصريح صانع المحتوى الشريره ضحى العريبي
كشفت فيه عن دخلها والارباح التي تحققها
عبر تطبيق تيك توك خلال مقابله
التلفزيونيه اعلنت ضحى انها تتقاضى نحو
6500 دولار امريكي خلال الساعه واحده فقط
من البث على التيك توك التصريحات اثارت
جدلا واسعا واعتبرها البعض نوعا من
الاساءه والاستفزاز كما تناقلت وسائل
الاعلام محليه وتونسيه اخبارا تفيد بانه
تم اخضاع ضحى للمراقبه من طرف الاداره
العامه للاداءات المعنيه بتحصيل الضرائب
من داخل المواطنين التونسيين بالبالغه من
العمر ابعته وعشرين عاما يتابعها عشره
ملايين شخص على تيك توك وصلت في لايف من
اللايفات
على تيك توك واثار هذا الاعلان جدل الكبير
كيف راقبتها الجدل يا ضحى والله الجدل كان
في صالحي مكانش مضر الي فالحمد لله يا ربي
ما شفتش حتى مضره وفي ناس يعني هي اغلبيه
الضجه صارت فهمت الناس الموضوع غلط ولسه
الناس فاهمين الموضوع غلط طب انت فهميهم
يا ضحى موجوده معانا على الهواء مباشره
فاهمين
من المتابعين ملايين من المتابعين انه انا
الناس صارت خلص بدها تلحق مشهور السوشيال
ميديا وهذا المشهور مش ماشي مثلا بطريق
التعليم وحمل الشهادات والتدرج في الحياه
كيف بتردي عليهم
برد اول شيء انا اخلي الشهره على جنب انا
انسانه زيي زيكم انا انسانه انخلقت زيكم
فلو انا بضر حياتي وبضر حالي على جال ناس
لا فانا صح ما كملتش دراستي لكن فيه اشياء
مثلا انه انا بذكيه خليت حالي عندي مدخول
خليت حالي انه انا شوف يعني لو كنت دير
مكنتش راح اوصل للي انا وصلت الحمد لله
لكن بشجع وبرجع بشجع انه انا لو كنت دارسك
كنت احسن من هيك لو كنت دارسه كنت احسن من
هيك بكثير انا بشجع الناس انها تدرس لانه
في اكثر من موقف
اي في انه اكثر من موقف محرج صار لي في
اكثر موقف مش حلو بسبب الدراسه انك تحس
حالك انك مش دارس انك مش عارف انك مش
متثقف فانا بحب مثلا اللي بيتابعوني
ودائما يعني الناس اللي بتفرج فيا حتى في
الستوريات واللايفات انا بقول يعني بتمنى
انه يتابعوني كل درسين انا بتمناها يعني
يكونوا اكثر ما يشجعوني هما اصلا يصلحولي
في الكلمات يقولوا لي هذه الكلمه غلط هذه
صح لازم لازم الدراسه لازم حتى لو مشهوره
لازم